hello everyone
welcome to my talk running a cadibus
testing lab
the roadmap to prepare for an iso 17025
i would start with the lims so here i am
my name is adrian i'm working as the
lims implementation expert
with cloudlimbs.com and today i'd be
walking you through
all the steps all the requirements
everything that you need to know
regarding making your lab an accredited
one
okay so we'll be covering
what is exactly this accreditation like
and what is it involved and what are its
requirements
and then why does your lab really need
it i mean i know you understand that you
know cannabis testing laboratory is
you know it's like an emerging business
it's got a huge market
but why exactly what a lot of the other
uh you know
points that you need to make sure for
your uh
journey in becoming a success
moving on we'll also discuss how can you
achieve it what
are these steps if do you need any
documentation
for this entire accreditation process
or is there any other body selection
that you can make or what's your
you know software and hardware tools
here if you like to understand that as
well
so let's start understanding what is
this
accreditation really like so the iso
17025 is actually one of the
biggest and by far the largest
and most critical and important
accreditation
standard which is a part of iso so iso
has about 20 000 standards overall of
which iso 1705
is being practiced by about 100 000 laps
already
across the world now you've got
a lot of parts where you need to uh you
can understand the nitty gritties of
you know the iso 17025 accreditation so
for example
the accreditation has a scope where you
as a lab would have to inform the
accreditation body
what all are your services that you
offer or what all are the parameters on
which you would be performing the
testing
what is the scope of your work do you
also do you perform like a full panel
test or are you only into potency
testing or
resident solvent testing etc so you'll
have to tell
the accreditation body at the time of
applying for the iso 1705 accreditation
you would also need to know about the
normative references
which the you know the iso accreditation
actually loops in which makes it at this
indispensable one
also you've got you know terminologies
you've got definitions in place
you've also got the structural the
process the
organization and the management
requirements which you need to kind of
fulfill in order to in one shot
get accredited by the accreditation body
so what's new really in the iso
iec 1705 so in 2007
2017 there was an update which was
released and it had about four
important points starting with the first
quadrant where we've got risk-based
thinking
it's shown so this basically gives you
an idea of
wearing a black hat when you actually
analyze your laboratories
uh you know future so you need to take
care of
all uh you know the types of analysis
you'll be performing
all the types of equipment you would be
utilizing do you have the adequate
guides in place
so that you don't leave any stone
unturned and
you can basically clear every part of
the audit processes
and become a successfully accredited lab
next
is the scope where it was revised so
earlier
uh you know your uh your labs were the
labs were only required to comply
or rather fulfill the testing and
calibration techniques
but now even the random sampling
techniques need to be taken care of so
for example
um you know there was a time when you
know the growers or the manufacturers
were about to send you their samples for
testing they would kind of hand pick the
best ones
from the lot i mean they may have
tainted samples as well they may have
you know samples which are not maybe
grown in the adequate
environmental conditions and perhaps
they may be
uh you know not up to the mark but just
so that they can get by this entire
milestone
they would send you their favorite their
most competitive their mo their perfect
sample
to the laboratory and the sample can't
do anything but to
of course generate the best results
because it's it's the correct sample
that they're sending it to
so the is that the laboratories
need to actually go out and perform
random sampling techniques
so that they remove any scope of errors
or manipulation here
we've got terminologies introduced let's
say we've got a new definition for
laboratory finally you can see in the
image showing the computer that this
actually acknowledges the inclusion
of a limb system which means that you'll
have electronic records taken care of
you'll have
all the documents being controlled
properly all your lab technicians can
remotely access
you know the notebook on which they need
to make entries and keep
the entire workflow requirements in
place so that all the team members
are informed at all time
next you can see the why so why am i
really interested in getting a lab
accredited
association to do file accreditation so
the reason
behind this is if you're already in a
region where
you've got legal requirements i mean if
you've got if you live in a state of
town where
it's mandatory for you to fulfill uh you
know the legal requirements i mean it's
required by the
ruling bodies or the government of that
particular region so of course
you have no other option but to you know
comply with the iso 1725 accreditation
next is the enhanced lab credibility so
there are a lot of growers manufacturers
or extractors out there who have a ton
of
options to send their lab to send their
samples
to the laboratory of their choice so
we want we would rather suggest that you
make your laboratory
such a laboratory that they kind of want
to collab and work with you
because it not only makes you earn
credibility it also guarantees that you
follow the correct procedures
and you also would be generating good
results which eventually would
make you a a more uh you know
serious lab testing um you know
statistical battery in your region and
also
across your uh
so next up is the lower cost of
operations so
for example if you take a case where you
receive a set of samples and you're
working on them and
you know when the results are generated
you realize that your equipments were
not calibrated
so you'll have to redo the entire
process because you at one point did not
you did not know whether or not your
equipment is in place to perform the
test
or let's say if your documents that
you're referring to if you
the documents that your lab technician
is referring to are not
validated properly so maybe you would
have to do everything all over one again
so therefore doing the same task over
and over again not only consumes time
but it would also add
to your increasing overhead expenses
and finally reduced risks and
liabilities
so cannabis testing market is a very
litigious
industry i would say and it actually has
a lot of risks
associated with it and you need to make
sure
that you don't get caught in any lawsuit
so at all times
regardless of you uh you know being
at any you know location you should try
to get your lab accredited with the iso
725 accreditation
so here is a map that actually shows you
uh all the leak all the states where
cannabis
testing is uh you know sorry all the
states where iso 17025 is legally
required
for testing cannabis now you can see
right from
medical status of legalization in
maryland or
ohio till the recreation recreational
purposes
in california or nevada
you've got this map which would serve
you to know
which to what extent is actually the
legal requirements spreading
and you know it's gaining momentum
across the united states
so you would want to make sure depending
on your region in the map
you would like to check with your local
and state bodies and make your lab
fulfill all such requirements
so with regards to the lab credibility
to manufacturers
now like i said you would want to be a
laboratory
that is known for its integrity it's
known for
the protocols that it follows it's known
for the accuracy and test results
and therefore the people out there who
are you know your
in in terms of b2b your your your
customers your target audience they are
basically the manufacturers or the
growers
or the extractors so you wouldn't want
to get their attention and you would
want to be liked by them
thereby earning their business and
growing your business overall
so what really reduces the operational
cost of the lab we we
kind of touched upon it briefly but if
you look at it
the entire workflow starts from you
receiving a test request and then you
know you're uploading the test results
uh you generating the co phase you kind
of sending the test for validation as
well
and measurement traceability plays a
critical role so
in case of a scenario where your
technician was maybe not qualified to
perform a particular test
so this person will of course generate
inaccurate results
next comes the productivity the
productivity
is of course if you've got a reagent or
an inventory which is beyond its
uh in expiration date and you don't have
a system like limps in place which
gives you no alerts so you're gonna run
your test
using an expired inventory which of
course would end you
up in generating inaccurate results now
with the quality assurance and quality
control
you've got like you know qc sample tests
you've got a set of
you know technical procedures and
documentation or a set of protocols
which need to be followed and all these
parameters combined all these
checkpoints combined
would either make you spend more doing
the same job
and also kind of not being successful at
it
or you can just turn the table towards
you and you know lead your way by
lowering the cost increasing the
productivity increasing the quality
and of course generating the accurate
results every single time
so now this is the main um you know
i would say concern of late because you
know
it's it's an industry which doesn't have
any federal oversight per se
so you would want your lab to be
protected
not only from the external parties
trying to falsely accuse you maybe
but also internally if you don't want to
fail any audits which are you know which
are surprisingly which are conducted on
surprise or maybe like a surprise with
it by the
visit by the auditors so what you can do
here is
you can basically make sure that you've
got all the documentation in place
your your staff is properly trained on
the kind of test they are supposed to
conduct
and in case someone files a case someone
kind of tries to sue you if they're kind
of trying to
uh you know a large lawsuit against you
so what you can do is in your limb
system you can
take them back from the very starting
point of things which starts from you
know
the correct environmental conditions in
which the test was conducted and the
correct sample amount that was
accession to the system or you know you
have your correct
people working on the said testing
you've also got already predefined sops
which can of course guide technicians to
take the right actions
and then finally you've got measurement
traceability which further
kind of assures the person firing or
rather
investigating the matter that you've
actually got everything in place and
therefore the results that you generated
are 100 genuine and they're correct so
you can actually defend yourself
from you know such uninvited trouble
so far we covered the what of iso 1705
and then
why do you need it now let's discuss how
can you really
go through this entire process and get
accredited
so there are some key requirements like
i categorize them broadly
right from process to structural to
general the technical
and the management requirements so let's
go over them very briefly
and what you can see on my screen is
confidentiality of
information being discussed so you've
got
uh you know on you've got a large amount
of people on your team let's say and
you're working with
partners and you're working with the
other people who might want to access
the same batch of samples and check for
various other pieces of
information so you want to make sure
that
you know your confidentiality is
maintained at all times you don't want
to over do or under do
uh you know entering of information it
might just
end up in wrong hands and you your test
results might get manipulated tomorrow
so this is important you've got your
organization with multiple people
uh you know having their roles and
responsibilities predefined
so you would like to make sure that only
the people who've got a particular
right or access are able to perform a
particular task
now a limb should actually facilitate
you
to make the selection so on my screen
you can see an image where you've got
various profiles created you've got a
manager profile or a technician profile
or a lab in charge profile
and for each of the dedicated modules on
the slims you've got
various actions that can be taken care
of so you want to make sure that you
make the right selection for
what kind of a person can be allowed to
perform what kind of an
action now comes through resource
requirements where you've got a personal
and you've got purchasing services and
supplies you know
embedded in it so you've got personal
which means
you've got like you know like i've
mentioned earlier you've got you know
various types of people where at various
roles in the team
and maybe it's only the lab manager who
needs to
have access to all parts of the product
also maybe sam is uh
let's say dr sam is competent to perform
potency tests whereas maybe dr susie's
uh you know competent enough to perform
only the homogeneity test
so you need to make sure that your
personnel is trained on the correct
activity and it's only them who work on
the
said task so that you you of course can
assure
the correct pattern to be followed and
correct for a test or substitution rated
the purchasing of services and suppliers
you actually work with
various vendors out there and so you
need to make sure the
reagents or the inventories that you're
receiving are actually up to the mark
so that they play because they play a
vital role in the overall
evaluation of your test results
now the limbs should be able to track
and maintain
all the records of the people on your
team with the you know
regards to maintaining their competence
the trainings that they've already
passed or are being currently conducted
and along with these statuses at the
time of assigning a test request from
the lims
your lab manager or your lab admin can
basically see
whether or not sam or susie is the right
person for the potency test
so with all the inventories that you
have in your lab you can actually
associate barcodes to them
you can then kind of associate all the
critical pieces of information to all
these barcodes
and you can make sure that you also keep
track of their expiration dates
and their depleting levels so if in case
you want to restock
you can set an alarm on the bims for
yourself so that you can restock well in
time
and you can also accept the request as
and when you receive and you
keep earning more business from your
potential customers
also like you can see on the screen
you've got a hydrochromic acid on the
top
row which is already expired therefore
at the time of association
to a particular test it would be
notified and you would not be
able to associate it with the set test
which is eventually
uh enabling you to perform only the
correct
processes and not end up generating
inheritance results
so now comes the process requirements
which starts from review of request
senders and contracts so at all times
you would want to be sure that you can
accept only those requests
which are which can be actually
performed correctly and meticulously by
a laboratory team
maybe the equipment is correct and
currently not ready or the concerned
staff let's say
dr stam for potency is dr sam for
potency
is not really available he's application
or perhaps your
uh
some checkpoint is supposed to be taken
care of if that's not in place yet
you should not uh you know accept the
test request that you receive
also it's uh kind of surprising that a
lot of employees don't realize the
importance of
calibrating and maintaining their
equipment so it's a must
and your limb should actually facilitate
it for you now you should also be able
to generate the coas in
your you know respective local and state
regulation
requirements and be able to share it
with the said
person so for example from california
when my customers so my customers
basically let's say for example
operate from california from the many
other states that they operate from
so the californian customers need to
upload a copy of the coa
uh to the bcc we are of cannabis control
right at the time they first generate
the coa
so your limb should also facilitate all
of these
functionalities which actually make your
journey of becoming a iso
17025 accredited lab much easier and
simpler
the test and calibration methods should
basically
for example let's say you're running a
culture testing
so you should be able to you know
backtrack and see
which methods were validated and were
they properly followed basis the
documents also associated with them
now if in case you're running a batch of
samples and
you know the test results are maybe not
up to the mark i mean as for your
understanding of them by looking at
or maybe by investigating the matter a
little further so what you can also do
is through measurement traceability
track the results of the backup samples
very much back
to the qc sample so now the qc sample
may be a spike or a duplicate or a blank
bank
let's say so if you're if you're if your
qc samples it is really spiked and if
it's
you know compared with the test results
of the samples that you just tested
and if the batch of samples that you
just tested say that
it's not really spiked so you can know
that there is
you know there is a difference between
the results generated by
qc sample which is which implies it was
spiked
versus the normal batch of samples so of
course
in this case you can rectify and take
some corrective actions
here and finally you would like to
ensure your quality of test results at
all times because that is what
matters uh eventually and all the steps
that we've discussed so far
is only for our aim to generate the
quality test results
so just taking a look at the review of
requests now here is a lims
screenshot which actually shows you all
the details
associated with this request now you've
got a catalog in place
you've got some samples associated with
it you can see who was the person
requesting this particular test to you
and what is the turnaround time like so
if this is something you can do
you should go ahead accept it and assign
the stars to the correct technician in
your team
once the test results are uploaded onto
your limb system
you should be able to get them validated
and you know your validator should
basically be able to generate
some share some remarks and approve or
reject the test
and leave me any comments by their
understanding of whether or not
the correct technical procedures were
followed
with regards to the equipment instrument
and calibration maintenance
of course you can track all the
components because a lot of times these
equipment have their individual
components and each component having its
own set of tracking information so you
need to make sure that
you know you know the software that you
use it tracks not only your equipment
information
maybe the person the agency who
purchased it from the vendor information
the calibration date and cycle and the
next calibration
date or let's say the previous ones
status
uh also being able to you know track all
the competent information
and eventually also assigning the
correct personnel
to perform a particular test on the
concerned equipment only
so all such pieces of information needs
to be in place
and that's what your limb should
actually assist you with
the management of qc samples like you
can see on the screenshot the one on the
third row highlighted in green that's a
qc sample
and above that are two normal batch of
samples now you can actually enter the
test results for this qc sample
and then when you do it for the normal
batch of samples you can make the
comparison
and see if there is a deflection in you
know the set of results
and accordingly you can approve
permission to tell
and you won't basically going
since you've got different stages of
different requirements of our culture
your limbs should do just that
so now let's talk about the iso ic
unique management management
requirements so you've got control of
records so let's say you've got various
people on the team
and you don't want and you've got
multiple user groups also
so you would not like a person from user
group one
to access documents or other information
which has been created
on the limbs by a person from the user
group too
so therefore you should always be able
to
make such pieces of information not only
confidential but you should also be able
to track
the transfer that has happened from hand
to hand for any sample
or test for example so maybe you've got
a sample in chain of custody and a test
gene of custody as well
so if a sample moves from the grower's
hands to the lab technician's hand to
maybe some other body out there
so you would want to make sure that
you've got all such pieces of
information
in place and with regards to the test
also
today your let's say the test is entered
or rather created by
personnel one and then maybe the test is
conducted by the other person
whereas the test is validated by the
other person so at all points you have a
different person controlling
the test case so you need to keep track
of all your
records and prevent them from any
unauthorized access
the document control would actually
allow you to upload documents to the
system
and you should be able to maintain all
the uh
you know sops in place all the other
associated
protocols which are let's say shared
with you or
shared with you by the manufacturer of
the equipment in your lab
you should be able to keep track and you
know manage all such pieces of
documents and data very very efficiently
and finally you've got an internal audit
requirement which actually requires
you to keep uh you know log all the
activities which are performed by all
the
uh lab personnel right since the time
you log in until the log out
along with the date and time stamp so
the software the lens that you use
should also allow you to uh lock all the
audit rails
and the internal login activities so
that it also becomes like a part of the
measurement traceability at times if
you know if you receive some uninvited
trouble so overall it's going to help
you get past that
now here is a screenshot for the
document control
you can actually track the document
versions like you can see there are four
versions
created and the fourth version let's say
is the latest version which your
uh equipment matters actually just told
you about
and this is the one that your
technicians should follow
so you can replace the previously
associated
sops with particular tests for you know
maybe
uh your your personal trainer or another
type of procedure
you can now just redo that and i'll take
your both your equipment and your
personal on the
of sop so that again you fulfill
the objective of accrediting with the
iso 725 regulation
so now comes the part where i can
actually talk to you about
how really can you start with this
process so you know about
what the presentation is why is it
really important
how do you achieve it you know maybe you
can utilize a limit there
but now really how do you get to the
very you know basic of
beginning what do you do tomorrow after
the stock is finished what can you do
that
so actually iso 725 gives you a window
of about one year also so that you can
maybe plan and apply and then execute
and then
you can get better at it and finally
receive an award certificate for that
so your first step actually becomes to
lay out your entire plan and then
pull in all the pieces of documentation
that would be utilized
and then finally select the right set of
software
run more products internally apply for
the accreditation
and win it and then maintain it
with a little more detail there so your
first step would actually become
your first step actually becomes for
your quality management system
documentation to be gathered
you can then share it with the iso
accreditation body let's say a2la for
example
and then they review your documentation
basically
an on-site visit to a lab and they would
evaluate of everything whether or not it
matches and they would probably
probably run a you know mock audit and
they would see
if everything falls in place if it does
they can
uh you know let you know about any
errors also
and you can then work on the corrective
actions pertaining to the same
once you're at this point and everything
now looks good
you they you would receive a certificate
for the accreditation
which you can now if they basically
promote or rather
you know it's like an earning it's like
a you know very uh
treasured uh achievement fail so you
need to make sure that you can also
uh kind of perform the a re-test
so that i mean in the sense you can kind
of enroll yourself in any proficiency
testing
so that once you actually surpassed this
process you also retain the
accreditation for
years to come
so now let's assume that we've already
achieved the accreditation
so now of course there are labs which
may or may not necessarily need so of
course there are labs which
at this point have managed have it
mandatory in the region
to get recreated with the iso 1705
but maybe you're a laboratory who is
just aspiring to be one of those
good and very credible laboratories and
you just achieve
your accreditation as well so now how do
you maintain it so you want to make sure
that you've got all the reassessment
evaluation
processes in place you want to do your
research and you would also like to take
pro take part in the proficiency testing
let's say the one
uh you know organized or conducted by
emerald so you have to
so basically random samples are sent to
all the laboratories
and of course emerald knows what the
correct result is like
and all these laboratories are supposed
to generate their results and share it
back
and that would basically tell the system
conducting that is conducting the
uh you know entire drill whether or not
your lab is someone who can qualify
these random surprise uh
you know proficiency tests and if it
does
you can keep track of your internal
audits also you can have them conducted
internally regularly you can strive for
continuous improvement you can
stay updated with what is latest in the
industry and what all
has been you know updated in terms of
the iso 1725 requirements
and once that is done you can also make
sure that
if ever you later on are willing to
expand your business operations let's
say today like i said
if you're only working on a potency test
and tomorrow you're working on
a full panel test you're adding more
feathers under the hood
or adding more feathers to the cap sorry
so you can
then let the accreditation body know and
you'll have to reapply for this new
scope that you're now expanding into so
every time
every every activity every service every
job that you're doing in the lab
needs to be informed to the
accreditation body because if only
you do that you would earn an
accreditation for each of the activities
worked upon by your laboratory
now you've got enough of information
about the what the why and the how and
the process and what's the life after
accreditation but
if we talk about you know the ground
zero and what becomes your
you know your intangible investment in
the longer run and how do you make the
correct choice for that so you have to
actually understand the difference
between a sample management software and
a limbs
so sample management software is more of
you know
is it's morally mostly required to track
all the sample information all the test
uh information only and generate
pertaining reports
but when you talk about a full-fledged
limbs it can actually do much more
it is it is the software you're looking
for if you're someone
exp aspiring your laboratory uh to
accredited to be a creditor to the iso
1725 accreditation
so you would want a lim switch does
everything that a sample management
software does
and additionally it takes care of your
lab inventory information it takes care
of your instruments calibration and
maintenance
it takes care of your packages which
contain you know the samples which can
be incoming to your lab or going out of
your lab
you will want to perform sample prepping
you would want to take care of all the
documents in place
and keep track of your staff training
and competence
and also generate current analysis
reports for any sample
for a given period of time so it's like
a full-fledged completely unified
solution
that is your go-to software when you
think about
iso1705
which brings me to the final leg of the
presentation just concluding what i'll
have we learned today
uh so we looked at why and what is
uh you know iso so of course it's the
single most important
uh regulatory challenge out there and
you want to strive hard to
learn everything about it and make your
lab legally credible
and also competitive in the market
because
even if you're really not you know ready
for the accreditation right now
you can start tomorrow and you've got at
least a one year window and tomorrow
when you're actually there
that's when you would earn more business
in your region and across and beyond
and finally you learned how a limbs can
make it easy for you
how is the process like how can you
actually
retain the accreditation how can you
continually
be an accredited laboratory in the eyes
of the world
so that's all from my side for today it
was lovely having you
and that's all from my side thank you
for leaving a lovely audience